Well, the difference is in the communication methods.
If you play with strangers,
everybody's going to be tight unless they go through discord. Uh,
everybody's going to be talking through chat and it's a lot harder to the,
the gym of this game comes not from the game itself,
but from the content surrounding the game. So the hilarious accusations,
the people turning like monopoly, like it's the ruiner of friends.
So.
If that's your real name,
are you Peter or are you an imposter?
Oh, I don't know what you're talking.
I think you do. I think you're a sus.
Okay. Who are you.
And what have you done with, uh, the host Richard Garner?
So yes, for people at home and for you, it is your old power Richard here,
but yes, that is among us lingo that we will be here.
The cultural phenomenon that is sweeping the world by the millions
and billions. Yeah.
So I get it now, the wildly popular game among us is what you're talking about.
A very popular among, among us. Yes.
It is very popular among us.
And so we wanted to take a deeper dive into this.
And obviously from the perspective of this particular show would have discussed.
What if among us was real? Oh, people will be very excited.
I think so. And, uh, but of course I'm not trying to fool anybody here.
I'm not the person to probably lead that charge or
answer those questions. You look like a Twitch gamer, nor are you.
So that's why we bring in experts like Leanna Rupert from game
informer. Thanks for making yourself AFK. And yes,
I did live in that yesterday. Um, Leanna, how are you?
Welcome to what if discussed?
I am great. Thank you for having me. I'm excited to talk among us,
those suss little Ash, not jelly beans.
I actually have in your, in your bio, uh,
self self identified among us obsessive. And I didn't make,
that was actually your words, right?
It is. I, uh, this game it's so crazy. This game, uh,
has been out for a couple of years, but only hit popularity recently.
And I totally fell off the map.
I didn't hear about it until I started seeing it climb on Twitch and I checked
it out and it's, it's the perfect game. It's, it's simple in a,
in an era where gaming is all overwhelming open worlds and it has
to either be game of the year or nothing at all.
Like the simplicity of among us is refreshing.
And I think what 2020 kind of needed, like we need just to relax and just chill.
And it also kind of gives us an outlet of rage because you literally just
accuse each other and yell around the table. Somebody wins or somebody loses.
And that's a good outlet for just letting out some of the rage of whatever's
going on in the world.
So it's a game that's being played by millions is being watched and streamed by
billions. Um, some of the most compelling Tik TOK content.
That's that's out there right now. And you mentioned it was launched in 2018.
Why do you think it's taken so long? And, uh, what,
why is it so popular right now? Basically just in the last month?
Yeah, it's, uh, it's kind of crazy. Like,
I feel like the gaming industry as a whole has kind of reinvented how it
approaches indie developers. Like I think eight years ago, I think,
and these were like this notion, but no big websites,
no big platforms were really devoting a lot of time to it.
And then we saw games like, uh, fall guys that kind of dominated,
which is another game about jelly beans that came out.
And I think over the last, I would say like 18, 19 months or so.
And these have really been kind of revolutionized and given a pedestal,
which is deserved in the industry. Um, but yeah, at first I think personally,
I mean, we saw a big jump in, uh,
on Twitch and that's where the popularity came from. You know, Twitch,
streamers influencers. They're really an official marketing arm now, uh,
for a lot of games. Um, I go to a lot of press events and things.
And now at the ratio between journalists and influencers is,
is very up and down because that is, that's a big queue of marketing.
And so we saw like a lot of people on Twitch,
but then everybody's kind of attributing,
Twitch being the reason why it's so popular,
but I don't think it would have even become a thing on Twitch if we didn't have
the game by media tonic, which is fall guys,
which is a game that actually got rejected many times by publishers that they
didn't think it would do well. And then the Twitter account,
I think gained a million followers within less than a month, maybe two weeks,
I think, and that came its own phenomenon,
but it's the little jelly bean designed.
So I think people were looking for that kind of a stylish ton of games.
And that's when a few key gamers happened to stumble upon,
uh, you know, another little jelly bean, astronaut adventure with among us.
And it went from having a usual average concurrent player base of eight players
worldwide to million of millions of players are now invested in this.
And so that's kind of a nice little conjunction between Andy and
relativity and the power of streamers. Hmm.
I mean, it's an interesting thing and you, you referenced it, uh, you know,
the old, keep it simple, stupid or kiss, right. I mean,
that's come up throughout, you know,
it sort of circles back throughout history where, when something blows up,
people often sort of resort back to, well, it just,
it seemed to hit people in this area and this area and whatever it is,
the product it blew up, it just sort of, you know, caught people by storm.
This is the case, but as it relates to gaming and you,
you talked about it off the top complexity became the default, right? Just
ostentatious worlds, highly skilled,
highly talented players. And now you have something come along.
That's re I don't want to say it's, lo-fi certainly simpler,
but also more accessible because you don't have to be a fantastic gamer to play
this. Right?
Yes. Uh, I think, uh, we kind of saw that with the big AOC stream,
uh, lately was, uh.
I saw, I watched that I was like, is AOC playing among us with,
was it a Valkyrie or a Valkyrie or.
Pokemon? I like a bunch of really big, uh, ma like it was,
it was a crazy turnout and she does play games. Like,
I think she's a big league of legends fan, but she's not known as a gamer.
She's not like, like some of us were, it's like our lives, I guess, Hopi
she's, she's a little busy, you know, she's a little busy, but yeah, no,
I think it's very accessible. Um, you know, there's the little death animations,
but it's nothing graphic other than,
I guess the next snap would be kind of considered a little graphic,
but the art style makes it accessible to all ages.
You don't have to be a pro gamer to yell at somebody saying they look
suspicious. Um, it it's,
it's almost funnier if you have inexperienced gamers on it because they don't
know kind of the talk and the lingo and that negativity kind of
actually works in their favor. I remember my first match it ever did.
I never played the game. I didn't know how it worked.
And I was imposter the first time. And I didn't know, you had to find task,
pretend like you were doing them. I didn't know. So I kept asking a chat, like,
what am I doing? Like work, where do I go? Do I go here? Do I go here?
And it kind of appealed to my teammates. Um,
natural wants to help me learn the game.
And it was the perfect cover stone when I saw that work and it was attentional.
I wasn't being manipulative. I was genuinely so confused. I was like,
wait that word, I could use that going forward. So if you ever play with me,
I just told myself that, I guess.
Well, the big, uh, the big,
what if for us today is what if among us was real,
but, uh, it seems like we may be a little late to the party or the parties.
I think it's a little crazy. I mean, there, there,
there was a fan that created like a FIAR version of,
among us that kind of makes it a little bit easier. Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah. Uh, that was really awesomely made. Um,
it was really well done and it kind of does put you in that mindset of like,
what if I was just doing random tasks and electrical and somebody just a friend
just came up and killed me. Like,
I don't think we could ever be walking jelly beans, but you know, it's,
I don't think it's implausible.
These are all self-contained maps of being on a spaceship and
oxygen eyes and everything. I don't think it's that far fetched.
I don't know why would want to do.
A bit of a reboot of like, you know, like, you know,
it's like everything old is new again. So there's, you know,
that sort of a mystery dinner, theater clue, you know, wink murder,
like who's, you know, who's, who's lying basically who, who,
who killed people, who's lying and,
and the rest of the group trying to figure it out, right? Like, it's,
there's a lot of different. I,
I play a little poker and that's obviously for the kids at home because I
play a lot of poker, but it's interesting because again,
when you start to zoom out and look at where are the commonalities in human
behavior that when something goes massive,
you have to start to look at what is the, what is the common denominator? And,
you know,
if I was looking at it from a poker lens and I was thinking that there's two
different types of experiences for poker, like, there's the, you know,
there's the, the home game with your buddies. And that's a really, you know,
that's, that's more social and more fun. Right. But also,
what is your friends easier to know when they're full of it? Right? Like,
not always, but if you've known somebody for 20 years and you know, their moves,
right. You know, their tells if you will, like Leanne is a yes,
but her sort of, Oh my God, I know what I'm doing. If yeah,
I got friends if they were doing that right away or the imposter. And,
but also what I've noticed is it's an entirely different experience when I
play with strangers friends, you know,
if you're in Vegas or at a casino and I enjoy both for different
reasons, what for you do you think is,
is maybe the optimum and maybe it's a personal choice, um,
to way optimum way to play among us.
Is it with friends or with people you don't know?
Definitely better with friends. Cause if you're not playing, if you,
if you play with stray, the difference is, is, is in the communication methods.
If you play with strangers,
everybody's going to be tight unless they go through discord. Uh,
everybody's going to be talking through chat and it's a lot harder to the, the,
the gym of this game comes not from the game itself,
but from the content surrounding the game. So the hilarious accusations,
the people turning like monopoly, like it's the ruiner of friendships. This.
Is the new rules.
This is, this is the new halo,
multiplayer where your friendships will be tested.
You just reminded me, honestly, like of,
of really like absolutely wildly intense board throwing
piece, throwing fi family fights monopoly back in the day.
Like it was crazy. It is like the absolute.
And I'm guessing in this because I have Watson videos. Like people do go nuts.
They, yeah, they it's, it's so funny. We were playing a match.
We're actually going to be playing again this weekend. Uh,
but we were playing a match with a couple of the game informer folks and some of
the people from the Washington post. And, and it's so funny because in public,
cause we're all journalists, we're very like, well, they are I'm, I'm not I,
but they're very professional and put together and just, you know,
how do you do? And then where do we go in this among us?
And it's just masks off claws out
and just like, no, just shut your mouth.
Everything like ambitions,
go to the wind because nothing matters when it comes to proving that you're
not sus you're not the imposter, even if you are.
And then you've got the other mechanics of which I learned actually this weekend
for the first time is the third imposter of if a person is not the
imposter, but they suspect you is,
but they want to help them for some reason that they will purposely misdirect
and blame other people. I don't understand why that's a thing.
I don't understand, um, what benefit there is to that.
But I've been accused of that a lot because I apparently I have no intuition
when I think I caught somebody. I'm like, they're acting really suspicious.
I'm nine times out of 10 wrong.
So I've been accused of being a third imposter a lot. It's like, no,
I'm just dumb. I guess.
Ecological profile machine. It sounds like. Well.
Leanna.
It's interesting because I think what the world would least need at this point
is, is a game that divides us into factions creates liars,
creates Meyers. Yeah. This is not something that's, uh,
that we're really should be looking for at this time set.
I guess also I guess the glass half full rage outlet.
Rage outlet, you get all of that out. You got issues with somebody,
but in among us.
We'd love it. If you could stick around for a few more questions, if you can.
Absolutely perfect.
Where can people find and follow you and read your reviews of, uh,
among us and other games?
Uh, you can find me@gameinformer.com. Um,
my social information is on there as well. Please. Don't make fun of me.
Every my tag for everything is there's an old gamer tag joke.
It's dirty F and hippie.
I'm glad you brought that up because I want to know what the source of that was.
Uh, when I was active duty, um,
everybody in my unit made fun of me because I always, no matter where we were,
if we were in the middle East or if I was on a ship, they, Oh,
I always had my guitar. And basically that, that, that, uh, I was a sailor,
but I went great sign to the brains, but I was basically the one that's like,
so anyway, here's wonder wall. I remember when we were in the middle East,
I was like sweat, you know, you're wearing a hundred plus pounds of,
of equipment. It's really hot. I was really sweaty. I was really gross. Like,
it was just like, sweat was just hair. It was like plastered. And I was like,
yo. So anyway, I started playing there, like, man,
she's such like a dirty hippie. And I was like, you know what?
I like it let's do it. Like, you can't really insult me if you insult me,
I just kind of adapt it. So I was like, yeah, I'm dirty up and hit me.
And it just kind of started.
Yeah. I, I, I, I just love the idea of somebody in like, sort of, you know,
full military, you know, Yama one.
That's all I can play on guitar too.
Yeah. Okay. Great stuff. Uh, we'll be back with, uh, Leanna Rupert, uh,
after the break. Um, and if you want to listen,
if you're watching and you want to listen. Yeah. You want me to click below,
right? Yeah.
We'll hear more from Leanna. We're going to check in with her.
On the other side, if you're watching the video podcast on YouTube,
then you're gonna want to click the link for the extended audio podcast below.
We're going to dive in more about the company behind, among us, uh,
inner sloths and the possibility of SQL to the game. Um,
but if that's all the time you have for us, thanks for coming out, then.
Thanks for watching. What if discussion.
[Inaudible].